Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich, This is Radiolab.
We're back from our break.
Yes we do. During our breaks,
what would you say we do during
our breaks? We don't do anything.
We don't exist really. And we're going
to continue with our show here. A today,
how many meditations?
1111 meditations on things relating
to death and what happens after,
but we're not up to
living. This is a five.
It's called four seconds down
from producers who are in wheeler.
Wake up. Everything's pretty black.
Same as Azman. Last couple of
weeks. This is Ken Baldwin.
The day he's talking about is August
20th, 1985. Say Goodbye to my wife
and I just say, you
know, I'll be home late.
Do some overtime at the time he used
to living couple hours east of San
Francisco. Say Goodbye.
Say I love her. And uh,
I know right now that I
won't survive the day.
She has no idea how I feel. Everything is,
is dark, everything is, is black.
So I get in my car, I'm, I'm just
not a very good person drive to work.
Cause I think maybe, uh,
maybe I can do it one more day
closer. I get to work the
more I realize I've, I've,
I've got to disappear to,
to start over and get rid
of whatever it is I've got.
It's got to end. I drive right
past work and then I'm on the, uh,
freeway kind of relaxed and I
finally see the bridge and it's,
it's huge. It's gigantic. He
parks his car at the bridge,
puts money in the meter and uh,
I start walking and I'm walking on the
bridge just like any other tourists.
It's a beautiful day.
It's a gorgeous Wednesday.
I see everything around
me and it's just gorgeous.
And I find a place, it's,
it's an outcropping.
You can see straight down
into the water and I say, uh,
this is the time to do it.
You really got to do this.
I really believed that everybody
would be better off without me
[inaudible]
that everybody would just
get on with their lives,
feeling better about me being
gone. Then me being here,
I put my hands on the, on
the railing count to 10
[inaudible]
and I vaulted over
and the last things I uh,
saw leave the bridge where
my hands and that moment,
that very moment
I said, oh my God, this is a mistake.
[inaudible] nothing I can do about
it. The fall from the bridge to the,
it takes about four seconds and it was
almost like a quick flickers of what I
was trying to think of my family,
my daughter, three years old,
I'll never see her grow up.
The things she's going to see
that I don't get to see man,
the misery that I caused. This is bad.
I'm sorry guys that I did this to you.
I do want to listen to
how it's going to end
and I just blacked out
and I woke up and I was swimming for
my life and I was saying, oh my God,
somebody please save me
somebody. Somebody saved,
he hit the water and a ball. He
bruised his feet, his backside,
but no serious injuries.
Some workers saw him jump
and called the coast guard.
And then the next thing I remember,
I was on the coast guard cutter.
Only 26 people have made it onto that
boat out of a thousand or so that have
jumped.
And nearly all of them say that in the
middle of the fall when they're facing
their death, something
inside them changed.
[inaudible]
they didn't want to die.
for Ken,
that change happened the very moment
he saw his hands leave the bridge.
I can see that perfectly.
[inaudible]
I can, I can, I can see my hands leave
the bridge. I don't know if it was a,
if it was a mechanical
switch or a, you know, um,
some kind of switch in the
brain function, but it,
for some reason it became
a switch to another life.
[inaudible]
number six
m a dead. Ooh, I hear some seagulls.
You hear the seagulls? Yeah.
Where are they coming from?
We just on the edge of the, um, the
English Channel on the Atlantic.
So they've got you in a little box
floating in the ocean. We don't actually,
we're not that far away from, from the
sea. So we get lots of seagulls here.
This is Paul Brock's, he's not really
floating in a box in the ocean. He used,
it's in a box near the ocean. And uh,
the reason we've connected our box in New
York to his in England is because of a
question he was once asked, you know,
if you work in this sort of line
that I've worked in over the years,
you get the most bizarre
statements and questions,
which is because Palsy neuropsychologist,
which means he diagnosis patients
with various mental disorders.
And he describes this one case about
eight years ago involving a woman named
Jeannie, just an ordinary pleasant middle
aged woman from the north of England,
early fifties well loved by her
family. She comes into his office,
he runs it through some basic tests.
I just did a basic assessment of as I
would in that sort of case of genuine
intellectual level. And at
first she seemed pretty with it.
She answered all his questions. He seemed
pretty alert. But then, well, she was,
she, we then go into a conversation
about whether things seemed real.
What does that mean? Well, it's
difficult to pin that one down.
She just felt that things weren't real.
She would point to objects in the room
and say, well, that cup that doesn't,
doesn't seem real, does it? Or
the chair doesn't seem real.
It just doesn't feel real. So I can
see it and I can describe it to you,
but it just doesn't feel real.
And the thing that really made me sit up
was when she said, um, I
forget the exact phrase,
but it's in the book. Um,
eventually Jeannie said,
am I dad and like to add? Yes. Do you
think I'm dead? Do you think I'd die?
I didn't respond immediately.
I let the silence flow.
Jeannie smiled. The face was
lit with a benign perplexity.
There was a smear of toothpaste
around the corner from that.
She didn't seem to notice the droplets
of tea spinning onto her dressing gun,
but there was a Glinton right in the
middle of the night. I was convinced.
She said, I thought they'd
come to take me away.
[inaudible]
I can't say for sure that
I'm dead. She continued.
The things are not the
same. I don't feel real.
It seems to me like he did.
How would I know if I was dead?
[inaudible]
immediately made me think. This might
be an example of coats syndrome.
No one really knows what causes Kotara
[inaudible] Syndrome. Very rare.
I mean I've come across three
cases, but one of the symptoms,
he says often this sense of deep sense
that you're somehow not completely here.
One idea about, um,
this syndrome is that somehow there's
a decoupling of thoughts and feelings,
which means what exactly
here's how to explain it to me.
The brain has two jobs.
It's doing it all times.
The first is to keep track of
what's happening outside your body.
Like the sites that are
coming out. You smell, touch,
your central experience of the world and
the most immediate consciousness of the
body and the world and the body
being in the world. All the while.
The brain also is maintaining this inner
life where you think thoughts and you
have memories, personality,
what you normally think of when you
think about yourself, you right,
what do you think happens in these,
in this condition? Is it that outer?
Are you, this was sensual
self somehow gets cut,
cut off from that inner mental
you and it just drifts off to
leaving you with just thoughts,
but it's the feelings that give us
our in the moment sense of self.
So if you don't have feelings
attached to forts and perception,
then you're like a vapor.
You're there but you have no weight
isn't what you're describing.
Basically one version of the
afterlife, like my body's gone,
but some thing remains.
Yeah, I hadn't thought
of that. That's very,
very interesting way to think about it.
But is that any different than the
story persisting in someone else's head?
[inaudible] seven
do you guys know this group? That edge
edge.org it's John Brock News Group.
Yeah, we do. That's David Eagleman
again and for number seven,
a brief excerpt from a conversation we
had with him. If I only had a brain, so,
so I just wrote an essay
on there yesterday.
It came out because this big ideas
that will change the world [inaudible]
exactly. Yeah. What's the thing that'll
change everything? And my answer was,
and I think this is something
I'll actually see in my lifetime.
So the idea is silicone and
mortality. In other words,
downloading your consciousness and do a
computer and we'll really have reached a
new point where there'll be a
mortality. Ah, how would you,
how would you figure this
would work? We did so.
So imagine you make an exact copy of
the three dimensional structure of the
brain. All the neurons, all the
connections between the neurons,
the proteins inside the
phosphorylation states of the proteins.
You make a copy of this whole thing.
What matters is the algorithms that
are running on top of the brain,
it's not the wet gushy stuff that matters.
It's what that wet gushy
stuff is implementing.
And the idea is that if you could recreate
the brain out of let's say beer cans
and tennis balls and you get all the
structure the same and it runs the same
algorithms, then that would be,
you would have your consciousness,
your memories, your
thoughts and so on. Yeah.
Right now it's science fiction
because it's so much data.
Our current computers can handle it.
Is that the only limitation? Just the,
the hard drive size? No. There's
other limitation where there are two,
there are two limitations right now.
One is our imaging technology and the
other is the amount of storage capacity
and error. I mean,
you get one Adam or two wrong and all
of a sudden instead of your cat named
cocoa, it's now named Boko and then
you're not the same person. No,
that's not true. In fact, because every
time you hit your head on a cabinet,
you're actually killing lots of neurons,
but that doesn't change who you are.
You don't miss remember
your cat's name. I mean,
imagine that you changed one
word in, in the novel, Moby Dick.
It would still be Moby Dick.
It'd be more almost Moby Dick.
It would be almost Moby Dick. But,
but you are almost the same person day
to day and you're never exactly the same
person that you were yesterday because
of the small changes in your brain.
But let's imagine that you're right,
despite Robert's objection not imagining,
let's just say you stick
to the Hubris of this.
What would you actually do with
a xerox brains to be immortal?
Don't you have new car? No, no, no, no.
But I mean you seen his own life. No,
no. But what, which, how would
you interface with a xerox brain?
So the idea is if we can recreate a
brain in zeros and ones on a computer,
then you could actually live
inside of a virtual world
and you could enjoy living
in this world indefinitely.
Or like the scarecrow
[inaudible].
If I only had a brain, he,
he didn't have a real brain.
He had straw and a certificate.
Well, you don't actually know that you
have a real brain either, right? One,
there are, there are modern philosophers
who deal with this in a very,
in a real way. They ask, how would
we know if we are a simulation?
Why would we die if we were a
simulation? He's not going die. Ah,
well, so this, this is
the point of my book.
Some is to illustrate that there
are lots of possibilities out there.
Right here it comes with you,
interrupt you because you're about
to become immortal. So there,
there are many different stories
written here and some of them,
God is actually a married couple that
got separated and then reunited or that
God is the size of a microbe
eight. Did we say eight or is it nine?
I think it was nine, I think were eight.
Um, ineffable. Another story by
David Eagleman and his books,
some read for us again
by actor Jeffrey tambor
when soldiers part ways at war's end,
the breakup of the platoon triggers
the same emotion as the well,
the death of a person. It's the
final bloodless death of the war.
The same mood Hans actors on the drop
of the final curtain after months of
working together,
something something greater
than themselves has just
died after a store closes
its doors on its final evening or
a congress wraps its final session.
The participants amble away feeling that
they were just part of something larger
than themselves, something they
intuit had a life, even though they,
they can't quite put a
finger on it in this way,
death is not only for humans but for
everything that existed and it turns out
that anything that enjoys
life enjoys an afterlife,
platoons and plays and stores
and congresses, they don't end.
They just move on to
a different dimension.
Although it's difficult for us to
imagine how these beings interact.
They enjoy a well this
delicious afterlife together.
They exchange stories of their adventures.
They laugh about good times and often,
well just like us, just like humans,
they lament how short this thing is brief.
It is.
It may seem mysterious to you that these
organizations can live on without the
people who compose them, but the
underlying principle, it's simple.
After life is made of
spirits. I mean, after all,
you don't bring your kidney or your
liver or your heart to the afterlife with
you. Instead, you gained independence
from the pieces that make you up.
Now,
a consequence of this cosmic scheme
is going to surprise you when you die.
You're aggrieved by all the
atoms of which you were composed.
Yeah. I mean, they hung
together for years,
whether in sheets of skin or communities
as spleen, but with your death,
they don't die. Instead, they,
they part ways moving off in
their separate directions,
mourning the loss of a special time.
They share together actually haunted by
the feeling that they were once playing
parts in something larger than themselves,
something that had its
own life, something, um,
well, they can hardly put a finger on.